et
ces rodéos
je suppose un stage d'argenton seront
effacés
on ne veut pas d'enfant
le poney 2010 c'est à dire que c'est le
successeur du poil et de mehdi parce que
moi dès qu'il est né j'ai voulu un
animal cheval a dans la vie de bon alors
j'ai pensé qu'un poney c'était plus à sa
portée
enfin ça serait bientôt plus à sa portée
avec celui là c'est un animal terrible
c'est un mort 10 heures alors j'ai
acheté tout de suite un petit poney
c'était ni gp du mans qui s'appelait
barbara et qui n'hésite lié beaucoup
attaché et c'est un peu à cause de ça
que j'ai écrit le fait qu ton poli c'est
à dire que j'ai imaginé la tendresse
d'un enfant pour un poney voilà voilà
les biens voila voila par des contres
populaire phone est sûr c'est mon
premier contact avec être la race la
race chevaline
mais ensuite je me suis attaqué à
beaucoup plus grand et beaucoup plus
forts s'agissait de j'ai eu un cheval
c'était un anglo arabe
évidemment j'étais cavaliers et jeu
comme on dit je l'exploité un peu je
m'en fiche mais cela sent
particulièrement libre c'est tout à fait
tout à fait ce qu'il veut je dire j'ai
une préférence alors là sans borne pour
le chat il est chat et je suis chialer
mais depuis très longtemps même quand je
crois j'ai dû tout petit je trouve que
les chats une stèle indépendance s'ils
sont très attachants pour ça par exemple
il a une longue histoire en finale une
histoire d'abord il est d'une lignée
d'aristocrates de chars bien sûr depuis
très longtemps et malheureusement le
moule et casser c'est à dire que je
crois qu'il sera le dernier
c'est bien dommage parce que il est très
très indépendant il est très marrant
mais en même temps c'est pas le chat
c'est pas le chat pépère 1
il va chasser ils ramènent toujours des
petits lapins qui le choix des [ __ ]
aragon mais il a l'air trés trés trés
lymphatique comme ça mais en fait il est
très très sportif mais alors vanille
c'est vraiment ce qu'il veut alors oui
alors moi j'ai un des choses et je
deviens complètement gâteux ou compact
de ça alors allez oui j'ai eu beaucoup
de siamois surtout mais aussi les chats
de gouttière tout simple et puis
un personnage aussi
alors ça c'est les deux fous du logis
c'est tous les deux été recueillis parce
que l europe ça ne l est impossible elle
est impossible à dresser sport c'est pas
quelqu'un civilisé sa gentille creux et
moi on n'est pas très civilisé alors
gérer des habits qui qui voulait la
donner alors la beauty 6 et lui
paris si tu veux te montrer oui tu veux
venir y alla alors lui s'appelle par ici
la bonne soupe parce que c'est une
histoire de garde champêtre
monfils avait 10 11 ans 11 ans je crois
quand il a rencontré le le par ici la
bonne soupe qui s'appelait je ne sais
pas comment mais qui avait terrassé par
dation tête et mehdi lui a dit par ici
la bonne soupe et il est venu il a
toujours gardé ce nom ça donne par ici
vatan et il a utilisé dirai pas ce qui
serait pas ici c'est d'aider pas comme
ça ils les fugueurs de sorte qu'on est
obligé de surveiller pour son bien un
peu parce que s'il s'en va il finira
sous un coup de fusil de chasse heures
pas contents ou ramasser d'une façon ou
d'une autre pour aboutir dans des lieux
qui me font un petit peu mal au coeur
celui-ci a déjà dix ans c'est déjà en je
ne sais pas exactement l'âge qui la met
à peu près dix ans celle ci aussi alors
on les aime d'autant plus tu vieillis ce
froid
si ces greniers d'ici que je travaille
c'est également le moment vous retrouver
ici votre environnement
c'est à dire les animaux l'an les
animaux ils sont synonymes de devis en
fait de vie comme la végétation comme
une vieille maison comme ils sont
effectivement une nécessité pour moi je
comprendrai pas une maison campagne sans
aliments vous avez dans vos livres
intimement mêlées les animaux les
humains pourquoi d'abord parce que j'ai
commencé en écrivant des livres pour les
enfants et il semble que les animaux
sont très proches des enfants et les
enfants très proche des animaux
ça commence par par le chiffon ou sans
peluche du nourrisson et ça continue par
l'animal qui finalement ne le montre pas
le premier rêve c'est de n'importe qui
choisit d'avoir un chez soi et bien sûr
des animaux parce que ça donne de la vie
ça apporte tout ce qui manque
s'ils manquent un être cher ou n'importe
qui il ya quand même un animal sur
lequel on peut
déverser son amitié
le